si el autismo también llamado trastorno
del espectro autista tiene unas
características particulares en
desarrollo social desarrollo
comunicativo y también características
en el comportamiento restrictivas y
repetitivas parte de los retos que
tienen las familias se dan en la primera
fase que es de diagnóstico que tiene que
ser temprano para poder abordar un
trabajo interdisciplinario en las áreas
de salud y educación
usted habla de la importancia del
diagnóstico temprano que avance de
sabido en la ciencia para identificar
esta enfermedad en un momento adecuado
bueno es importante aclarar que la
incidencia es de 1 de cada 160
nacimientos per dependiendo en las
investigaciones podemos hablar de unas
cifras mayores y en este trabajo dentro
de los procesos de salud pública se ha
intensificado precisamente poder lograr
esos procesos de valoración y
diagnóstico que permitan una ruta de
atención pertinente para el trabajo con
la población con trastorno del espectro
autista y estos dos años de pandemia
obligaron a que millones de estudiantes
de todo el mundo no pudieran ir
presencialmente a las escuelas como
afectó esto a los menores de edad que
tienen autismo
bueno cuando se vive en torno al autismo
es importante saber y reconocer que se
vive en un mundo de segregaciones y
exclusiones de allí han sido unos retos
importantes sobre todo para reconocer
sus estilos de aprendizaje
revisar un poco más también este trabajo
de apoyo a familias que es tan relevante
y también posibilitar esas acciones
desde las políticas públicas educativas
particularmente que garanticen pues un
enfoque de derechos para todos los niños
y niñas que tienen la condición esa es
como el reto que tenemos hoy día estamos
en una transición evidentemente donde
hay muchos retos en el tema de la post
pandemia alrededor de la educación pero
confiamos en que todos estos tránsitos
nos traigan las experiencias importantes
significativas y valiosas alrededor de
la atención y cobertura para la
población señora jiménez y muy
brevemente usted es madre de un adulto
con autismo cuáles son los retos que
enfrentan las familias
claro que sí tanto para la infancia a la
adolescencia a la adultez los retos son
muchísimos a medida que van creciendo en
la adolescencia y pues para la población
adulta se van minimizando esas brechas
de participación para ellos aquí el
trabajo se da desde una labor
intersectorial desde las políticas
públicas que garanticen pues toda esa
ruta de atención de acuerdo a este
enfoque diferencial reconociendo
particularmente esas habilidades que
tienen cada una de las personas que se
encuentran dentro de la condición del
espectro autista